Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
the American dream continues.
Iyer: We've created a device
to make your kitchen
not only safer
but smarter, too.
I have the wedgie
of my life.
‐Whoo!
‐[ Laughs ]
This could be
a really big product.
You're a smart man.
‐What are your sales?
‐$250.
‐Oh!
‐Whoa.
O'Leary: You value this company
at $10 million.
You haven't sold
doo‐doo yet.
I don't want just the money.
You lie!
We are ten times better
than everyone else
selling clothes to guys.
You can't keep
on saying that!
We need a shark
in our corner.
I don't think anybody
wants to work with you.
The Golden Ticket
goes to my favorite product.
Take it or leave it.
Herjavec: Oh, my goodness.
♪♪
Narrator: First into
the the Tank is an accessory
to make cooking cleaner
and easier.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Yair Reiner
from Brooklyn, New York,
and I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange
for 10% of my company,
Frywall.
Frywall offers a simple elegant
solution to a problem
that every cook knows
and hates ‐‐ splatter.
This is what your stovetop
usually looks like
when you're cooking.
It's splattered
with oil and sauce,
and it's sprinkled
with bits of food.
It's disgusting,
and you spend 10, 15 minutes
cleaning it up every time.
Frywall offers a simple,
elegant solution.
It's a silicon guard that rests
inside the lip of your pan.
Whether you're making tomato
sauce or cooking up bacon,
Frywall keeps the sizzle
in the pan
and the splatter
off of you and your stovetop.
[ Bacon sizzling ]
Unlike a lid
or a splatter screen,
the Frywall lets you see,
stir, and flip your food
at any time without ever
losing protection.
It's also great
for making stir‐fry
or for cooking down
a huge pile of greens.
Smells good.
Oh, good idea.
Now, Sharks, please, don't try
that without a Frywall.
[ Laughter ]
When you're done,
just slip the Frywall
into the dishwasher and then
roll it up for compact storage.
Cool.
Sharks, you've shown America
how to bring home the bacon.
Now help me control the mess.
I'll pass out some samples
along with a glass of wine
you get to enjoy instead
of cleaning your stovetop.
‐[ Laughs ] You're a smart man.
‐Ooh!
John: Good idea.
Herjavec: Yair, I hope it's not
Mr. O'Leary's wine.
I wouldn't dare.
[ Laughter ]
That'll get you a deal
right there.
Greiner: You're out.
[ Laughs ]
John: Thank you.
‐That's great. Thank you.
‐Enjoy.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐Cheers, everybody!
Cheers.                Cheers.
Cheers.
‐Salud.
‐Cheers. Cheers.
‐To Frywall.
‐Cheers.
Nice wine.
That's a good start.
Will it burn?
So, it's made out of silicon,
which has been used
for bakeware for ages.
So it's safe to 450 degrees.
How did you come up with it?
What's your background?
So, I came up with it because
I've always been a home cook.
I invented this thing
in my kitchen,
and then I saw that nothing
like it had ever been done,
and everything I knew
about business
about cooking told me
this could be
a really big product.
But, boy, it is really hard
to leave a paycheck
for the great unknown.
‐Yep.
And then one day I went to work,
and I found out
that the company I was
working for was getting sold,
my division
was getting closed down,
and I was gonna
be out of a job.
So they made
the decision for you.
Three months
after finishing my job,
I had a prototype,
and six months after that,
I was out
in the market selling.
‐That's motivation right there.
‐That's right.
‐Yeah.
‐Is this patented?
Utility patented.
Cuban: Yair,
what do you sell them for?
What do they
cost you to make?
On average, they cost $25
and $5.50 to make.
And where do you
sell them?
About 70% of our sales
are online.
What are your total sales?
So, we launched the product
a year ago,
and we've done a total
of over $800,000 in sales.
Wow.
Good for you.
That's impressive.
Right now, we're in about
55 independent retailers.
Did you get approached
by any of the large retailers,
like Bed Bath & Beyond
or Walmart?
Walmart, the price point
doesn't work for them,
and Bed Bath and Beyond,
I'm talking to the buyer now.
I like your story,
I like your product.
I'll give you $100,000
for 15%.
No royalty, Kevin?
O'Leary: No. Straight 15%.
I know what's happening
with the Walmart buyer.
I've been selling Walmart
my whole life.
When they put a price point out,
that's what they want.
They know what sells
in their stores.
Herjavec: You're very credible
and you're killing it.
I just don't know how
I can help you with it.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
If I were to give you an offer,
do you have other ideas?
I just want to know
where do you see it going?
Right now, we have penetrated
this market this much,
so there's opportunities
I think to potentially
license the brand.
There's opportunity
to maybe brand
or co‐market
with home delivery companies.
See, but okay ‐‐
It makes no sense, then,
for you to go into stores.
Why would you even
mess with that
when you're killing it online,
you have margins ‐‐
He has to, Mark.
He doesn't have a choice.
‐Of course he does.
‐You don't have a choice.
When you have
a fantastic product,
you don't have a choice
but to compete
with any knockoff
that's gonna come.
‐No, because ‐‐
‐You have to.
You go to stores,
all of a sudden,
the size of your company
has to grow exponentially
because you have
to deal with them,
you have to engage
with them continuously.
He has to do that.
If you're online
and you go to the Alibabas
to preempt the knockoffs,
that's where you get
your greatest strength.
Alibaba will take
all the knockoffs and him,
and they'll be cheaper,
and then the other ones
will get the money.
‐Where do you want to go?
No!‐ I mean ‐‐ No!
‐Yeah, that's how it works.
I want to ask you
a question though.
May I answer
Daymond's question?
‐Yeah.
‐We're all trying to, you know,
determine his business
strategy.
I want to hear it from him.
Where does he really want to go?
Where I want to go is have
a defensible business
and one that's profitable.
Whether the protection
comes from IP
or protection comes from saying,
"You know,
everybody get out of the way
because I'm putting my product
here in the store
so you can't."
All right. I believe
you should go retail, as well.
It's free advertising
with some valuable real estate.
Ugh.
It brings people back
one way or another.
I'm gonna offer $100,000
for 15%, as well.
I'm gonna
show you something.
You know what this is?
‐You gonna make an offer, Lori?
O'Leary: Are you gonna do
the corny thing?
‐The Corny thing.
‐Corny thing.
This is my golden ticket.
It's real gold.
The Golden Ticket goes to my
favorite product I've seen.
‐Oh, my Lord.
‐I have a guitar pick.
[ Laughs ]
What this means is,
I'm going to give you
exactly the offer you came
in asking for ‐‐
It plays guitar.
‐Ooh.
‐the $100,000 for the 10%,
and I will also fund
your purchase orders,
giving you a line of credit
indefinitely.
The question is ‐‐
are you going to take it
or leave it?
O'Leary: Do you have anything
to say, Mark?
I want to see.
Lori, I think you would be
an amazing combination
for this product.
I'm the perfect combination
for your product.
Because I think you know how
to get into retail.
I think you know ‐‐
I know you know how
to get into retail.
‐And infomercial.
‐I got a counter.
$100,000 for 10%,
and I'll give you
my gold tooth from high school.
[ Laughter ]
Ticket?
I love the offer.
I love the ticket.
I do want to hear if Mark
has anything to say
about this deal.
‐Ooh!
Herjavec: So you don't
love it enough to take it,
even though she's giving you
exactly what you're asking for.
Wait a minute.
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Yair has three offers on the
table for his kitchen accessory,
Frywall, but he may
jeopardize the offers
by waiting to see
what Mark does.
The Golden Ticket goes to my
favorite product I've seen.
I love the offer.
I love the ticket.
I do want to hear if Mark
has anything to say
about this deal.
‐Ooh!
Herjavec: So you don't
love it enough to take it,
even though she's giving you
exactly what you're asking for.
Wait a minute.
I have worked really hard
to get to this point ‐‐
Yair, first time
I'm giving my Golden Ticket ‐‐
exactly what
you came in asking for,
an unlimited line of credit,
as well, only taking 10%.
O'Leary: But you still want
to hear from other offers?
I think it would be
disrespectful to Mark
not to let him have ‐‐
This Golden Ticket
could vaporize.
♪♪
Cuban: You know what?
I'm out.
Lori, we have a deal.
‐Agh, that Golden Ticket crap.
‐Good! [ Laughs ]
‐Oh!
‐We are going to crush it.
Yeah.
And it's real gold.
Here.
‐Oh, boy.
‐[ Laughs ]
I'm putting my guitar pick
back in my pocket.
Congratulations, Yair.
‐Thank you.
‐Great job.
Lori, go like this ‐‐
You've got a lot of syrup
all over you.
Oh! Come on.
You know, when I lost my job,
I could have gone
and tried to look
for another job in an industry
I didn't like anymore,
but I followed my dreams.
Yes!
Lori is the one who can get
the product on TV,
she can get it into stores,
and I think with her,
this product is gonna go
everywhere really, really fast.
Narrator: In Season 5,
we watched Nick Taranto
and Josh Hix make a deal
for their meal kit
delivery serviced, Plated.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
Taranto: We made a deal
with Mark Cuban.
Unfortunately,
we couldn't come to terms
and the deal fell through.
Hix: About a year later,
we were fortunate enough
to run into Kevin O'Leary.
He got excited
about the progress we'd made
and invested in the business,
and the rest is history.
When we pitched on "Shark Tank,"
sales were $350,000,
and this year, we'll do over
$100 million in sales.
These guys are going to now have
access to 35 million customers.
Plated was just acquired by
Albertsons for $300 million.
Man: What percent return did
you make on this deal?
1,346,
but who's counting?
This is the biggest acquisition
in Shark Tank's history.
‐Hey, Kevin!
‐All right!
Taranto: It's hard to overstate
how huge this deal is.
Customers can now walk
into an Albertsons store,
pick up their Plated meal,
just like you would
with any other
grocery product.
By the end of 2020,
our goal is to do more
than $1 billion in sales.
You're a household name
in America now.
You guys have done it.
The thing I love about
"Shark Tank" is that it allows
millions and millions
of Americans to understand
what it's like to start
and build a business,
and I hope we can inspire
more people to go out
and really swing
for the fences.
$300 million.
Cheers.
[ Cheering ]
It was a rocky road.
First I said no,
then I said yes,
and am I ever glad I did.
This is an amazing outcome
for Nick and Josh.
They're gonna become bigger
than ever because they got
a giant corporate partner
to make this
a billion‐dollar business.
To Plated.
‐To Plated.
Yeah!
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a workout
innovation for parents.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
Thank you for the opportunity.
My name is Pier Paolo Visconti,
and I'm seeking $500,000
for 40% of my company.
So, Sharks, a few years ago,
I was on the phone
with my sister who just had
the second baby,
and she was complaining
about the extra
pregnancy weight.
She didn't know
how to exercise
and stay with her child
at the same time.
So I knew right there
that I needed to come up
with a solution,
and what's better than combining
the most‐used aerobic
machine by women
around the world
and a conventional stroller?
So that's how I got the
idea to invent the very first
Elliptical Stepper Stroller
in the world.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Interesting.
Cuban: It's only
missing one thing.
[ Horn honks ]
Yeah,
where's the baby, Paolo?
Well, I'm working on it,
actually.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐[ Chuckles ]
Cuban: That's cool.
So, Sharks,
this is the very first time
that you can actually
use a stroller
as a fitness machine.
So the Elliptical
Stepper Stroller
is composed by two elements ‐‐
the carriage
and the elliptical
stepper mechanism.
Now, the elliptical stepper
mechanism folds in and out,
so you can use it
as a conventional stroller
or a sporty one.
So, Sharks, I spent a lot
of time, money,
mistakes to show the world
that this was possible.
Now let's get together
as a team
and show the world
that this is a reality.
‐Wow. Is this a prototype?
‐This is a prototype, yes.
O'Leary: Okay. And these patents
you've received
are all on this prototype?
Absolutely, and actually,
I have seven patents.
How much have you spent
to get to this point?
Wow.
$170,000 of my own money.
‐How much?
‐$170,000.
And how much of that
was just for the patents?
‐$72,000.
‐Wow.
Do people just get on it and go,
or do they have to train?
‐Is it hard to use?
‐It's a stepper, right?
Okay, your fitness level
to use this stroller ‐‐
Let's say I get on the
elliptical every day ‐‐
Let me try.
I got to try.
Get out of here!
[ Laughter ]
Kevin,
you get in the stroller.
‐All right.
‐Go ahead, Robert.
‐Yeah, Robert, is it easy?
‐[ Laughs ]
It looks like it's
a reverse elliptical.
You have a brake on the right.
Oh, on the right?
Okay.
[ Horn honks ]
‐It seems to work.
‐All right.
Close the doors,
and let's go.
It's like a clown car.
I have no insurance!
Herjavec: It's cool!
Get it up to speed
and see how easy it is to stop.
‐It's a little unstable.
‐Brake. Brake.
‐It's only a prototype.
‐Yeah.
‐Exactly.
‐Let me give it a shot.
Brake, brake.
Robert, have you ever
been on a stepper?
Yeah, many times.
This is an elliptical.
Does it feel just like a stepper
but kind of...
It's a shorter step.
Yeah.
Go.
‐He's gonna fall.
‐It's gonna pop a wheelie.
You're not athletic.
Paolo, it's because
it's a prototype, right?
‐Yes.
‐So you haven't sold any yet.
No. No.
I'm in the prototype stage
What is it gonna sell for?
What would be the price?
‐So, I had two models.
Actually ‐‐
‐It weighs a ton.
‐What are you doing?
‐He broke it.
$48,000,
that stroller.
Wow.
Um, it's $48,000, Kevin.
It has functionality,
but I got a big
question mark here,
Paolo.
‐Yes.
‐This thing weighs a ton.
‐It is incredibly heavy.
Yes.
How is a woman supposed
to pick this up
and put it back
in her car?
Okay, first of all, this,
it doesn't weigh too much
because it's all aluminum.
The weight is here.
I understand ‐‐
I understand...
Couldn't that
be aluminum, too?
Like once you make
the real thing?
Yes, but, Paolo, how is she
gonna put it in the car,
to Kevin's question?
Why you have to put it
in the car?
Would you put it in a car,
a jogger stroller? No.
To go to the park
or whatever.
Because I go to the park,
I'm going somewhere else.
Well...
I always have to put my jogging
stroller in the car.
Okay, but not all the jogger
strollers are foldable.
‐Yes, they are.
‐Yeah, they are.
Not all of them.
Paolo,
what did you do before this?
I'm a real estate broker,
and I came into this country
with 400 bucks in my pocket.
Guys, no money.
Actually, one night,
I was sleeping ‐‐
no mattress ‐‐
I was sleeping on the floor,
and then I feel like
something here.
It was a cockroach.
‐Ew.
So what I started doing,
I started working three jobs.
Eventually after three,
four years,
I was owning three apartments,
and I got into real estate,
and I work on this project
only on my spare time.
It's interesting that you're
successful in real estate.
You take the money
you're making,
you put it into this,
with the passion
for solving this issue.
This is not me
solving an issue.
This is creating a brand.
There is a need for this.
Women want this.
If you ‐‐
I went to South Pointe Park
in South Beach.
We couldn't do,
like, 10 yards
without being stopped
by women.
Okay, Paolo ‐‐
Paolo, look,
if you had priced this at
$50,000 for 10% and grow, maybe.
$500,000.
You're right, the company
is not worth $1.25 million,
and I understand that,
but that's the money
I need to go
into production
and make these.
‐First, look ‐‐
‐Yes.
You don't need money
for production
until you have potential
customers, right?
I have people
that send me e‐mails
that they want to buy it,
but I need to go to testing.
There are other steps.
I was gonna say,
have you done
the safety testing
and all of the tests
that you need to do
for child safety stroller?
That's why I'm here and that's
why I'm asking ‐‐
‐Okay.
‐You haven't done that.
No, I have not.
Paolo, you put so much
of your energy
into getting patents,
and this is such
a mature industry
with major manufacturers
that already have
established distributions.
Why haven't you gone to them
and said,
"Look, I have these patents.
This is gonna solve a problem.
‐License it.
‐License it from me.
Sell them for me,
and I'll take a 7% royalty."
‐No risk.
‐Because it's easy to say,
but I cannot go to...
‐Why not?
‐...and go inside the company ‐‐
Herjavec: Why?
Why can't you
just call them?
They will license it
if I have a brand.
You have taken the hard road
to establishing market share
in the stroller market.
From scratch.
It doesn't really make sense
for me to give you $500,000
so I can compete
with companies
that already have achieved
massive distribution globally,
but I don't have to reinvent
that whole business
to be part of it.
I could just license it.
You don't seem to want
to take that path.
No, I didn't say that.
I didn't say that.
You told me you couldn't
even get into their door.
Because I can't put too much
meat on the grill.
Okay, look, Paolo, for me,
I don't see it, okay?
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay. Okay. Thank you.
Cuban: Paolo,
it's just too big of a swallow.
$500,000 ‐‐
You know, the risk‐reward
just isn't there for me, Paolo.
I'm out.
Okay. I understand.
I understand.
‐Paolo.
‐Yes, Lori?
I'm not willing
to risk $500,000.
So, unfortunately,
I have to be out.
You know, you made one
of the most critical mistakes
that almost all
entrepreneurs do make.
How did you get to the point
where you had enough money ‐‐
$170,000
to invest in this?
How did you
get to that point?
You were sleeping at home
with a roach on you,
and then all of a sudden,
you had that type of money?
Hustling. Hustling.
‐Hustle, right?
‐Yeah.
You didn't have money
when you did it, right?
No.
You knock on door
to door to door.
Yeah.
I made my biggest mistake
when I finally got money.
I thought that money
could solve the problem,
and I spent $6 million trying
to build a brand that failed.
You see,
because you had that money,
that's why you made
the mistakes.
Because before that, you know
what you would have done?
You'd have taken
an existing stroller,
you would have repainted it,
cut the back off of it,
and welded
something on there.
And then you know
your next step?
You go to the ABC show
and all those children shows,
and just like people stop you
every five feet on the beach,
those buyers and manufacturers
and producers
will stop you as you're riding
around the show.
Money's
not gonna solve it.
You're gonna have to go out
and do this on your own.
I think you can,
but at this point,
I can't give you the money,
so I'm out.
Okay. Can I ‐‐
Paolo, you know,
you are so deeply excited
about this and passionate
about it,
but you got
to stop designing,
you got to stop
getting more patents.
You have to have
the same level of love
and passion for the product
in terms of sales!
Go sell one.
Today, you have crowdfunding,
you have Instagram.
There are different ways
to sell stuff today.
You don't need ‐‐
‐I don't want just the money.
That's the point.
I don't want just the money.
I want somebody like you ‐‐
But you asked
for the wrong amount, Paolo.
For $500,000,
I can't get on board.
I'm out.
‐Wish you the best.
‐Thank you so very much, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Me, too.
‐Good luck.
‐Goodbye.
Bye. Thanks.
I understand that maybe asking
for $500,000 was too much,
but I didn't have anybody
to compare my idea.
So in my mind,
that was good to ask,
you know, for $500,000.
Obviously it wasn't.
How long can somebody keep
doing that elliptical?
Isn't that like
a 10‐minute thing,
and then you're
kind of...?
No, I do an hour of elliptical
every night.
‐You do?
‐I do, too.
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, my God.
I burn 500 calories
doing that every day.
That's what I do.
‐You do?
Every day.
47 minutes every day.
You're just stepping, up and
down, up and down, up and down?
And what's
your heinie like?
‐I look terrific.
‐[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product that aims
to prevent a common and
dangerous kitchen accident.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Akshita.
And I'm Ranjith.
And we're the founders of Inirv.
We're asking for $800,000
in exchange for 8%
of our company.
Oh, my goodness.
‐Whoa.
‐Whoo.
Sharks, how many times
have you gotten distracted
while you were cooking?
Whether it was screaming kids
from another room,
a phone call
that got you distracted,
or even worse ‐‐
you left the house
with something
on the stove?
Well, Sharks,
you're not alone.
This happens to millions
of people
all around the world
every single day.
These situations not only cause
you to burn your dinner,
but can cause
deadly kitchen fires.
And that's why
we've created a device
to fix this problem
and make your kitchen
not only safer
but smarter, too.
Introducing Inirv,
a truly innovative
kitchen device
that quickly detects hazards
in your kitchen
and automatically
turns off your stove
so you never have
to worry again.
Here's how it works.
Simply replace
your stove's knobs
with our smart knobs,
and place this sensor unit
on your ceiling.
As soon as you turn on your
stove like you normally do,
both units will activate.
If the sensor detects dangerous
levels of gas, smoke,
or inactivity
in the kitchen,
it will automatically
turn off your burners
so you never
have to worry.
Also, you can monitor your stove
from our app at any time.
So just simply tap the button
and it will just rotate off.
‐Very cool.
‐So, Sharks,
who's ready to help
us get this revolutionary device
into every home
and onto every stove
so people around the world
get the peace of mind
that they deserve?
Where are you at in the
development stage? Tell us.
So, we've had a functional
prototype for several months.
We've been making aesthetic
refinements because it's
a consumer‐facing product,
and also we've been making
technical improvements.
We launched
a Kickstarter in February.
We had a goal of $40,000,
and we raised 438% of our goal,
so $175,000.
‐Wow.
‐That's 694 pre‐orders.
Ranjith,
how did you come up with this?
How did you invent it?
‐Yeah.
So, a few years ago,
Ranjith and I
were actually in
a very serious car accident.
I broke bones throughout
my entire body,
most prominently my hips
and my neck.
So I was in a wheelchair
for four months.
‐Ouch.
‐Wow.
At that time,
my mom came to live with me
just to help me out,
and on more than one occasion,
she kept leaving
the stove on.
After I started
walking again,
I had gone for a movie
with my mom.
About 20 minutes in,
she turns to me and she goes,
"Akshita, I can't remember
if I turned the stove off."
I was like, "Oh, gosh!"
So we quickly rushed home.
Fortunately, we got back
before a big fire had started,
but we had a lot
in smoke damage.
So I said,
"Why isn't there a product
that makes the stove smart,
and why isn't there something
that can just retrofit
onto a stove that
you already have?"
Ranjith,
can you take that off
and bring it over her
so I can see it?
Sure.
The name of the company
is Inir‐v?
‐Inirv.
What does it mean?
So, it comes from the medical
term "to innervate."
We both have medical
backgrounds.
I graduated from Duke
with a Neuroscience degree.
Greiner: Wow.
And I was actually
in the process
of applying to medical school
when I came up with this idea,
and I really saw this space
as ripe for innovation,
and so I literally dropped out
of the medical school
application process to focus on
this company full‐time.
I'll tell you a little bit
about my background.
So, I'm a resident neurosurgeon,
and I went to ‐‐
‐You're a resident neurosurgeon?
‐You're both in neurosurgery.
‐Yes.
‐Wow.
‐Where?
‐I went to college in Atlanta,
got my Bachelor's
and Master's in four years.
Bachelor's and Master's
in four years?
‐Right.
‐What took you so long?
I know. I watched a lot of TV,
what can I say?
"Shark Tank."
‐[ Laughs ]
Okay, so now ‐‐
But this is mostly mechanical,
though, right?
Because you're using
off‐the‐shelf sensors.
It's not really secret sauce.
‐Yeah.
It's not very protectable,
and it's got to lead to
something else, right?
Well, wait, wait. Why is he
saying it's not protectable?
Is it protectable?
‐Absolutely.
So, we've done
extensive patent search,
and we've filed multiple
provisional patents.
Herjavec: What's your vision
of going to market with this?
Yeah.
Because you haven't sold any
except Kickstarter.
What we're
working on now
is for you
to pre‐program recipes.
So, say you know
that your chicken cooks
for 10 minutes on high,
five minutes on low,
and then off,
which most recipes
are pretty standard
that way.
You have to put your chicken
on the stove,
but then through our app,
you can click that recipe,
and it will modulate
the burner temperature for you.
Why wouldn't the manufacturer
of the large stove
platforms...
Thank you for asking
that question.
...just hire you as programmers
and do that?
Or someone else, frankly.
Because if they control
the distribution,
they control the device?
‐Yeah.
‐Yup.
So, with this device,
and I realize you've got
to have a broader vision
because I frankly think
in 36 months,
this will be obsolete.
‐What are you talking about?
‐Why are you saying that?
No, I agree with him.
I agree with him.
This is our entryway
into the kitchen.
This is a pain point now.
I mean, our Kickstarter
we sold because people identify
with the fact that they want
that peace of mind,
that they can just
turn off their stove.
Yeah, but that's only 700
orders,
that's not really
indicative, right?
Sure.
John: Those sales through
Kickstarter ‐‐
what was the price
you were selling?
You sell four knobs?
We sold it as a kit
of a sensor and four knobs,
and then you can add
additional knobs.
‐For how much?
‐If you have more burners.
And how much was that?
And the average order price
was $250.
Cuban: So this is
a nice‐to‐have product,
but the bigger picture is,
this is hard‐sell market
because even though
it makes common sense,
even though you think people
will have enough
self‐interest, they don't.
That's why people die,
because they don't have
their smoke alarms
or they turn them off
or take the batteries out.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Whether it's a retrofit
that goes onto the stove
or we license our technology
to an appliance manufacturer,
this technology
will be there.
I like the long‐term vision.
I get all that.
Appliance manufacturers
have approached us already.
Who called you?
We're already in discussions
with three of the largest
appliance manufacturers.
Look, but I have another
question about manufacturers
with this product right now.
‐To license?
Yeah. To license
and white label it.
Correct.
I'll give it a shot. I'll give
you my honest opinion, okay?
$800,000.
I like money.
That's a lot of it.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐I'd give you $800,000.
From what I've heard today,
I see some massive challenges
in rolling out
the existing product.
For me to get back
my $800,000,
I fear I'm gonna die
of old age
because I'm getting
practically nothing here.
So ‐‐
You value this company
at $10 million.
You haven't
sold doo‐doo yet.
Yeah. Sure.
So let me say first ‐‐
‐Hold on. Guys.
‐Yeah.
Speak to these Sharks
'cause I am out.
‐Okay. Appreciate it.
‐Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Now, before you tell us
the size of the market
or things like that ‐‐
Everybody tells us that,
but I hope that's not
what you're doing.
‐No, no.
‐You know, I like the product.
I'd probably get it
for my mother.
You asked for $800,000.
You would probably
have to sell $200 million
worth of products
and we get a distribution
for me to even break even.
That's with you not
making any mistakes.
So ‐‐
I don't think you can do that
within the next three years,
and I hope I'm wrong,
but I'm out.
‐Okay. Thank you.
‐All right. Appreciate it.
So, let me just say something
about the valuation.
I know it's high...
but this is part
of $2 million seed round.
I'll take the seed round.
But not at 8%.
‐Okay.
I'll give you the $800,000
for 20%.
‐Wow.
‐Oh!
Thanks a lot for the offer,
and so I'd love to counter,
and here is my rationale
before I give you a number.
If we stifle our valuation
at this round
and give away too much equity,
we're not going to be able
to raise a large growth
round and really scale. So...
No, I respect that,
but I guess I have a slightly
different vision.
‐Okay.
‐I don't want to build a company
that you're constantly
gonna raise money at.
‐Okay.
‐Let's build some.
‐Sure.
‐Let's sell some.
Yes.
And that will increase
the valuation
so you have to raise a little
less money down the road.
Sure.
I don't have a lot
of flexibility on it
'cause I see a lot of risk.
You got to go to market.
‐Sure.
‐Yeah.
‐I appreciate it that, and ‐‐
What's your counter?
You said you were
gonna make a counter.
Yeah. So, can I counter
at $800,000 ‐‐
Can we make it creative?
I'll do it Mr. Wonderful style,
in a way.
‐Yeah.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Can we do $800,000
for 10%
but 2.5%
in advisory shares?
So that way, it doesn't
directly impact the valuation?
Grasshopper,
you are learning.
Yeah. I watch this show.
I just watch TV all the time.
Yeah, that's good.
It's interesting,
but I'm stuck at the 20%.
If you can do it,
I respect that, I'm out.
‐Oh!
‐He went out. Ooh.
Well, we're so far apart.
‐Appreciate that.
‐Thank you.
I freakin' love the concept.
I am that person who goes,
"Did I turn it off?
Did I turn it off?"
So I'd love to have this.
I'd love to be a part
of your journey.
My biggest problem is this ‐‐
I don't see
a finished product.
So I'm worried about ‐‐
Is it going to work?
For $800,000, I need to see
that working product,
and I wish I did,
but I don't.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay. We understand.
Thank you.
‐I appreciate your time.
‐Thank you.
‐All right, good luck.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Appreciate that.
Thank you.
♪♪
‐Wow.
‐Ugh.
It's like such a smart
needed product ‐‐
$800,000.
And yet, it's ‐‐
Lori, were you gonna
give them $800,000?
If it was a working product
that I knew was working.
‐Oh, come on.
‐I didn't care about that part.
‐See, I really did.
‐If they had someplace to go,
I'd give them that money
in a heartbeat.
I have a little bit of regret
about not taking Robert's deal.
You know, thinking back,
I think I may have pushed him ‐‐
I should have pushed him
a little bit further
to see if he would be willing
to lower his ask
because he would have been
a great partner for us.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a
duo who believe
their version of a men's garment
is the best out there.
♪♪
Dude.
I forgot my lines.
It's like
a sauna in here.
[ Laughs ]
My name's Peter.
‐And I'm Chris.
And we are birddogs shorts.
We're here from New York City
to give you the opportunity
to invest $250,000
in exchange
for a 1.5% stake
in birddogs.
‐Oh, my goodness.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐1.5%?
‐Whew!
Birddogs are gym shorts
with a built‐in liner
that makes underwear obsolete.
Done.
Well, there you go, Mark.
[ Chuckles ]
‐Underwear ‐‐
‐Oh, my God!
‐Makes no sense.
‐None!
Why would you wear
a pair of shorts
underneath your shorts?
What, are you gonna wear a glove
over top of a glove?
You're hiding
your thunder.
You're mashing and shaming
when it should be
a point of pride!
I mean, you're not gonna
throw a lampshade
over an Oscar,
would you?
No way!
Or jam a loaf of bread
into a shot glass.
‐It's not gonna fit.
‐No way!
Underwear is beyond
uncomfortable.
We combine
the feel of nudity
with the function
of a fanny pack.
I mean, look at this.
We got a phone pouch,
got a wallet pouch,
and two hand pouches.
And feel how soft
these babies are!
You're never gonna want
to take them off,
and you don't have to.
They dry faster
than your bathing suit,
and if you want to dress it up
and impress a girl,
you can easily wear
these on a date.
That first pair of birddogs
hit your door,
and you slide that liner
up your thighs ‐‐
‐Ooh!
‐And that liner hits your boys?
Whoo!
‐Whoo!
‐That is comfort.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Now, we're talking about shorts,
right?
Let's pretend this watermelon
is the fruit of your loins.
[ Laughter ]
‐Oh, my God.
‐Don't get it on my clothes!
[ Laughs ]
All right,
fire in the crotch!
‐Oh! [ Laughs ]
‐That went well.
‐Whew!
‐All right, so maybe birddogs
don't work
on watermelons...
I told you.
...but they will work
on your berries.
Guaranteed.
‐Oh.
‐Berries.
So, Sharks...
who wants in
on this sweet deal?
‐All right. So...
‐Yeah.
I don't understand the
watermelon thing, but...
That was an attempt
at humor.
We actually have pairs
of birddogs
for you guys
that we brought along.
‐That's a good start.
‐We do.
‐Yep.
‐One for each of you.
So, here we are.
Daymond.
‐Thank you.
‐Top is yours. Yep.
‐This is Lori's?
‐That is Lori's.
‐Oh, you have a female version?
‐Here you go, Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you.
‐No, we don't.
‐Here you go, Mark.
‐Okay.
I guess a female
could wear them.
We're not
gonna stop them.
‐Thank you so much.
‐You're welcome.
So it's like built‐in underwear,
but it's loose.
I'm not sure what's different
versus a pair of workout...
These are gym shorts.
Yeah, they're the best pair
of gym shorts on the planet,
but it's about
so much more than that.
They're the most comfortable
thing a guy has ever worn,
and he wears them
every excuse he gets.
How many of these
have you sold?
We are one of the
fastest‐growing
men's millennial
brands out there.
I started three years ago.
Our first year,
we did $200,000 in sales.
Last year,
we did $2.1 million in sales.
Wow.
And this year, we'll do
$6.3 million in sales.
Nice. Nice.
How in the world
did that happen?
[ Laughter ]
So, I had spent
my first four years
out of Harvard Business School
working my way up
the executive ranks
at IBM.
I'm on a business trip
in the middle aisle,
can't move, and I have
the wedgie of my life.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐It's in this discomfort
that I decided to,
number one ‐‐
I'm done climbing the corporate
ladder. Quitting that.
Number two, I'm gonna make
a pair of shorts
that makes underwear
obsolete.
I drive to a gym,
and I sell birddogs
off a folding table
in front of gyms.
It sold quick.
I bought more inventory
and began to build
the building blocks
that are birddogs today.
Chris, why is it called
birddogs?
"Birddog" is a term
that Peter and I
have been using for years
to classify and describe
a guy that, honestly,
we look up to.
A birddog is a guy ‐‐
He could put 36 beers
in a parka
and sneak his way right
into Fenway with ease.
He's the guy that's getting
free guacamole on his tacos.
‐What do you sell one pair for?
‐Wow.
We sell birddogs for more
than it takes to make them.
All right.
That's why you went to
Harvard Business School, right?
[ Laughter ]
We sell birddogs exclusively
online for $55.
‐Wow.
‐It costs $18 to make.
That's a 67% gross margin.
Online, guys buy 1 1/2 pairs
of these on average.
That's an $83 order value.
Now, we only have to pay
for three things.
The shorts, shipping
to get them to your door ‐‐
6 bucks ‐‐
and marketing.
$13 on average per order.
‐Oh!
‐Wow.
13 bucks
to acquire a customer?
‐$13.
So, what happens is,
each time that cash register
rings online, 37 bucks hits
our bottom line.
That's almost
a 50% margin.
We actually have an intern do
37 push‐ups
every time
an order comes in.
He's a big chest guy.
‐Well, he is now.
So,
why is your cost so high?
Number one, we have the best
product on the market,
and it's because we spend
five times more
than everyone else.
Number two, we have the best
marketing on the planet.
Not if you're spending $13,
right?
Greiner: Wait. Why?
Why do you have the best
marketing on the planet?
‐So.
‐Big statement.
When we sell guys,
we approach them
by telling them a joke
like he's at a bar.
We show him entertainment
and not advertisement.
But the bigger
question is ‐‐
If my numbers are right,
you're spending about $400,000
a year on marketing,
right?
We spent about 20%
of net sales.
So this year,
we'll do $6.3 million in sales,
so that means we'll spend
$1.2 million on marketing.
You're making my point,
right?
If the advertising's good,
the less you should
have to spend,
not the more
because it'd be more viral.
People would be sharing it
on Facebook more.
Sure.
Because that's the whole point
of doing it this way.
‐Sure.
‐Right?
Your customer acquisition
should be going down,
but hopefully the effectiveness
of your ads is going up.
Right? So you see that
something's not right.
It suggests that the majority
of your videos
are not as effective
as you're trying to tell us.
Okay, but let's talk about
our competition for a second
in one key metric ‐‐
e‐mail marketing channel,
which is arguably
the most important.
The average open rate
amongst our competition is 4%.
‐What's yours?
‐40%.
‐No way.
‐No, no.
‐40%.
‐No, that's a false statement.
‐No way!
‐40%!
‐You lie!
Not only is it 40%...
[ Laughter ]
half of the guys that open it,
forward it.
My question is ‐‐
For you to drive sales,
you're driving the cost
of marketing like crazy.
So to get to $12 million
in sales,
you're gonna have to spend,
what,
$2.6 million on marketing.
‐Well, not exactly.
‐Not necessarily.
So, first off,
we are 10 times better
than everyone else
selling clothes to guys.
You can't keep on saying that!
‐Why? Why do you say that?
‐Wait, wait, wait.
Herjavec: Peter, have you raised
any money from VCs
in these last three years?
I have raised money over
the last three years.
‐Oh, you have?
‐What valuation?
Yeah.
I've raised $560,000
from our friends.
We sold at a valuation between
$3 million and $9 million.
So at this point,
we've sold 11% of the company
for $560,000
in outside capital.
You walk in the door here
and tell me
you're worth $16 million.
‐Sure.
‐You're crazy.
‐And you're offering me 1.5%.
Do you think I'd actually
get up in the morning
and think of you
if I own 1.5%?
No,
that's their whole point.
‐So, look ‐‐
‐[ Laughs ]
Typically,
companies come in here
and they have a flaw
in their product
or a tweak in their marketing
or they're in the mud
and they need to get out
and scale,
but we got the product
and the marketing right,
we got through the mud.
What I'm asking is ‐‐
We need a shark
in our corner right now.
‐Why?
‐Because my friends
don't have the financial
wherewithal
to continue to find
our exponential growth.
But you're gonna make
$1.3 million.
Greiner: You know what,
honestly...
Guys, how much cash do you have
in the bank?
So, right now,
we have about $600,000.
How much do you have in
inventory?
So, this single‐biggest problem
we have is 1/3 of the time,
we have no inventory.
But you have $600,000
in the bank.
What's your lead time?
Six months.
So put yourself in my shoes.
Six months?
You have a six‐month lead time
to make your shorts?
You're so full of [bleep] though
and everything you guys
are saying.
Narrator: All Sharks
are still in,
but there are skeptical
about Chris and Peter's answers
regarding their men's shorts
company, birddogs.
Your investment
in your inventory
really tells me
what you think you can sell.
If you're the best
at everything,
how can you not
be planning ahead
to have inventory
constantly coming in?
Why would you have $600,000
in the bank?
‐Because you'd be ordering ‐‐
‐Great point.
Even if they had the money,
if they had the advertising ‐‐
All this work
that you're doing...
Yep.
So, Lori ‐‐
...you would be absolutely
having orders go in every month.
You would never run out
of inventory.
Exactly.
So, this is the biggest
problem we have.
It takes us six months
from the time we order
until the time
the shorts arrive.
Six months from now,
we'll be doing about
$3 million
in monthly sales,
which means I need $1 million
in cash to pay
for the inventory in six months.
Now, six months from now ‐‐
You know what, you're
bird‐dogging the answers always.
I'm out.
‐Hold on. Right ‐‐
‐Ooh.
‐One second.
Right now,
I've got to make a decision
every time
I make an order.
‐Your numbers aren't adding up.
‐Do I shoot beyond our demand
and risk potentially putting
the company out of business?
No! What you're saying
makes no sense.
Well ‐‐
And I'm surprised
you don't understand
that what you're saying
makes no sense.
How doesn't it make sense?
O'Leary: Guys, let's stop
for a second and ask a question.
‐Sure.
‐How do you think it's going?
Uh, I don't know,
I mean...
I actually think if we can get
serious for a moment,
a lot of the Sharks
think you're full of B. S.,
and that's a problem here.
I know! The number
are too good ‐‐ Listen...
‐Too good to be true.
‐No, no, no, no, no.
They're not ‐‐
No, no, no, no, no, no. No.
You were going
to say that, right?
‐But, look ‐‐
‐But they're true!
I'm gonna make it simple,
Harvard Business School simple.
If you expect your sales
to more than double...
Mm‐hmm.
...in the current year,
that means all your cash
should already be gone
if you truly believed that.
Well, Mark, good point, except
we're a seasonal business.
You have the world's
best marketing!
Your sales are going through
the roof! You can't keep up!
Everybody else,
you're disrupting
the hell out of them
because they don't understand
the millennial market?
So you're saying why
don't we just turn
the marketing machine up more?
‐I sense some skepticism.
You know what, why aren't
you just ordering ‐‐
Guys, either you believe
or you don't believe.
Brands grow at a certain rate,
all right? Meaning...
[ Laughing ]
Now you're dialing back!
‐Hold on a sec here.
‐Wait a minute.
You know, we're learning so much
from you, it's amazing.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: Because you're saying
one thing on one side,
and then another thing ‐‐
Thank you!
I never thought of that.
Why aren't you buying
the inventory now?
Because they don't believe.
It's not a matter of belief,
it's a matter of risk.
Isn't that the definition
of risk?
How much do you believe?
‐It is, but there's risk
and then there's
smart risk.
Look,
if you were a true birddog,
and you were willing to put all
those beers in your pocket,
you would say,
"I got this." Right?
And the money's in there
because we're all in.
That would be confident,
but it might be foolish
because if I over‐order
on inventory...
You couldn't come out here
any more arrogant
or confident than you did.
I'm out.
The more you talk,
the more present it,
the more unclear
the story became.
I'm out.
Daymond is
the clothing guy.
‐So, yeah, um....
‐What are you gonna do?
It seems like you were
teaching us business.
You were also telling
us about how
you're better
than everybody else.
So you shouldn't be talking
about other people like that.
I think it's a very elitist
attitude,
and I just wouldn't be able
to work with you.
So I'm out.
O'Leary: Okay, guys.
In all seriousness,
what happened here today
is you have $6 million in sales
this year.
That would normally get
a lot of interest here.
But you're arrogant.
You're paying the price for it,
and I don't think anybody
wants to work with you.
It's not funny, it's true.
I'm out.
And you are dead to me.
Get out of here.
‐All right.
‐Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Wow,
that went sideways fast.
What a couple of [bleep]
‐They were arrogant as hell!
‐Totally arrogant.
Greiner:
They thought everything they did
was the best of the best.
‐They made Kevin look bad.
‐"The best! The best!"
They were the best until
they had to put their money
where their mouth was
and invest in inventory.
Mason: I felt like it was
a little bit
of almost bullying
just to bully.
We have
an incredible product.
It's 10 times better than
anything else in the market.
We're growing
like gangbusters.
We've managed to do it
profitably.
What else is there?
♪♪